hello everyone and welcome to the second
day of the world Fisher random
Championship it is Mathias bluebound
versus Magnus Carlsen and uh it's uh
truly a game that
um makes you wonder about how great life
is it's it's like reading good poetry
while someone is feeding you your
favorite cake only better uh on on a on
a nice sunny day let's say something
like that it's hard to say because it's
a really nice game uh which you guys
will see and it's a very short game
basically the game uh sets uh uh a
decisive tone already as of move seven
uh but yeah we're gonna discuss that
fairly soon it's a really weird position
as you can see there are uh Knights on
all four corners of the chessboard which
is very nice that's why I put um
something Lada posted on Twitter he said
who said the Knight on the rim is dim
and now we have a four nights on the rim
uh so let's see how the players use
those Knights and the Knights are used
quite well in this game and also before
we check out the game I would just like
to address one a little thing yeah I
didn't know I I I will be addressing
this because I I didn't think anyone
would really fall for it but more and
more people are sending me messages
asking me if I have promised them a
PlayStation 5 or a uh iPhone or I don't
know something because someone in the
comments with my profile photo and um
well seemingly my channel name and also
on telegram has contacted them and said
that they have won a prize so I can
assure you uh no one will contact you
online assuring you that you have won a
prize especially another big one like
like a PlayStation 5 or something like
that and not only like like 15 maybe
even 20 people have contacted me already
and some of them even said that they
have paid like fifty dollars for
shipping or something like it's a
complete Madness so don't fall for that
and it's very easy to check you can
click on the actual profile you can see
if it's my channel you can see if it's
my tell program account so don't you
know fall for such scams online
and you know stay stay very safe as
usual but yeah now that that is
addressed and now let's check out the
game so Matthias has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to E4 and Magnus
replies with Pawn to F6 which is usually
a crazy move in regular chess in this
position it seems to be a great one and
it was employed on other boards as well
and if you remember even in regular
chess uh Thomas Wilson Barnes defeated
Paul Charles morphy with Pawn to F6 on
the first move but uh you know those
were different times but okay now Pawn
to F6 we have Knights the B3 we have D5
by Magnus striking in the center both
the rook and the queen are supporting
the pawn pawn to F3 and now Pawn to E5
grabbing the entire Center e captures
and queen captures on D5 bringing up
your queen uh too early never a good
idea but again this is a chess 960 and
Here pawn to D4 preparing to open up the
D file and open up the white Rooks
attack towards the queen for the moment
you can can to do it the Rook on D1 is
undefended but Matthias has plans of
playing Bishop to E2
so here Knights the B6 by Magnus Bishop
to E2 Now The Rook is defended and the
Magnus plays Knight to G6 and already uh
something very very cool is about to
happen uh here we have D captures on E5
which is a bit premature you should just
continue developing with something like
G3 or Knight to F2 but after d captures
on E5 yes magnus's Queen is now hanging
but there is something Matthias missed
in this position uh that Magnus uh
prepared so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this idea while I give
you a couple of seconds
foreign
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing the
connection between the king queen and
Bishop and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Knight to
F4 this is what Magnus played and now
Matthias is in great trouble uh what can
he do here uh seemingly you could
capture but uh and it seems like it
should be good for you the problem is
you have to calculate really far away to
see that it's actually good for you I
will show you the line because it was
not played if real captors on D5 Knight
captures I need to with check for King
The King and the queen now King to D1
now you're gonna play Knight captures on
G1 and after Rook capture Sun d8 King
chapter 78 e captures an F6 let's say G
captures it seems like black is up a
piece as you can see black is up a light
Square Bishop you will win back the PC
will play Bishop to F2 and now the
Knight is trapped and now uh Magnus will
just pick up the F3 Pawn G captures on
F3 and you will get a disposition which
symmetrical Pawn structure pretty much
but
[Music]
Magnus would have a a bishop for a
knight so it's two Bishops a knight and
Rook versus two knights bishop and Rook
but the position would be uh well
heavily favored in uh for black uh as
the games on both sides of the board so
the bishop Crews will be very powerful
this was however best white had in the
actual game Queen TEF 2 was played and
now the position will be uh somewhat
different Knight captures than E2 first
we have Queen captures on E2 and now
Magnus plays Queen captures on D1 with
check Queen captures we have Rook
captures on D1 King captors and now look
at this queen side castles beautifully
done the king remains uh where the King
was but now the Rook just comes to d8
and the delivers check and this is
something one could definitely miss when
calculating all of this but Magnus goes
for it and now it will be incredibly
difficult to defend this the problem is
Bishop is coming to G6 and you will not
be able to defend the C2 Pawn you could
play something like King the C1 but
again it's not the the greatest of
squares or you can just play F capitals
and E5 the Knight can come to C4 uh
imagine if the bishop ever yeah you know
assumes this diagonal so it's not gonna
be it's not gonna be pretty plus you
already moved the king how are you ever
getting the Rook into the game so
instead after this castles with King the
E2 now comes the bishop to G6 now you
cannot defend your Pawn uh e captures on
F6 Bishop captures on C2 now which tempo
as The Rook is hanging so Rook to C1 and
the bishop to D3 with check we have King
F2 and only now G captures on F6 so now
Magnus wins his spawn back and the
Bishops will now fight against the
knights with Knight the G3 uh Knight the
A4 again how are you defending the B2
pawn bishop to C3 and Dot Magnus
eliminates the other Bishop as well so
Knight characters Rook captures and
Bishop back to G6 uh we have Knight to
E4 and now Pawn to F5 by Magnus Knight
to C5 and now just the bishop to G7 so
now the bishop pair is almost fully
operational Rook the C2 now adding a
Defender to the B2 pawn and now Bishop
to F7 uh we have King te2 you can't
really move the Knight
um yeah you can't really move the pawn
because then something like B6 moves the
Knight and then this Knight hangs so the
the two knights defending each other is
never a good idea so upon the B6 by
Magnus Knight to D3 and not just King B7
are preparing to go C5 improve his
position on the queen side uh Knight to
D2 and now we have Rook the E8 with Trek
King D1 we have rooked the E3 grabbing
more space Knight the C1 and now even
Pawn to C5 so you can see how the
knights are really struggling to play
against those Bishops uh B3 and now even
a beautiful Bishop to C3 by Magnus
completely paralyzing white and now this
Knight well this Knight can move in
that's even a good move but the Rook
cannot move the Knight cannot because of
rookie one Checkmate so it's very hard
to continue best for white and probably
the only way to maybe save the game is
the to actually go for this Knight's Day
2 attacking the bishop and after the
bishop moves now you can play Knight to
G3 you go after the pawn and the once
Magnus defends it now you go after the
Rook so you really have to go crazy with
this Knight to Rook the D3 now King E2
this is how you get the king into the
game and after Rook D4 maybe now you can
play this but still the bishop pair is
just uh extremely strong here so instead
Rook captures on C3 was played a nice
offering of a of a exchange by Matthias
Rook captures on C3 and now Knight the
F1 we have C for now by Magnus and King
to D2 and it seems like Magnus blundered
The Rook here but this is what Magnus
had in mind he wants to give back the
exchange and just keep a winning
position Rock captures on C1 King
captures C captures on b3a captures and
Bishop captures so now Magnus is up only
one Pawn but it's two connected pass
points on the queen side and again games
on both sides of the board he has a
bishop of course so he is much better
here
so Knight G3 we have Bishop D6 defending
the pawn and now Knight the H5 King to
C6 of course Matthias will try
everything Knight to F6 going after H7
so H6 with Pawn to G4 and now King to D6
we have Pawn to H4 King to E5 and now G5
Medias also creates a pass Pawn of his
own captures captures and the king the
F4 and he was in this position on move
39 that Matthias bluebomb resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here and now the the pawns will just
start marching forward the bishop is in
a beautiful spot here controlling this
light Square diagonal uh and there's
really nothing to do if you start
advancing the pawn just King here I mean
now the Knight has to move the pawn will
hang you cannot sacrifice the Knight
because the bishop covers the queening
square so that's out of the question and
okay one thing that you maybe can do is
uh defend your pawn and and try to hold
on but I mean it's really not all that
difficult you just push the pawns and
win for those of you who like me to
finish games let's say Bishop F7 you
have to prevent the pawn to G6 or rather
you should let's say King to B1 and I'll
just start pushing pawns Pawn to B5 King
B2 white will waste some time Point A5
King to C2 uh A4 and I are gonna go King
to B2 Pawn to B4 and now after King to
C2 A3 King to B1 even B3 and after King
day one now you can just bring your king
in and Checkmate the white king let's
say King E3 Knight to F6 now the Knight
can come into the game B to check King
to B1 King to D3 and now of course once
the B2 Pawn will be uh defended uh A2
will be Checkmate whatever white plays
doesn't really matter King C3 and now
let's say you go here A2 will be checked
it's only one of the ways you can do
this but the after King F4 Matthias
resigned and a wonderful Victory uh for
Magnus uh who gets a nice Victory after
his loss yesterday against Hikaru
Nakamura Wesley also had a very nice
game against the animation he defeated
him in their first game uh so that will
definitely mean a lot Jan will have to
strike back otherwise he uh is very
close to dropping out of the uh
competition because uh well abdusader of
doing incredibly well Wesley now beating
him in game one uh he will have to
strike back uh so we'll see what happens
there and I will keep you guys informed
uh yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it stay safe don't trust
strangers on the internet even if they
have a profile photo of someone that you
know it it might not be them actually
behind the account so always you know
click on it and check if it takes you to
the original account uh and yeah just be
be safe in general uh so yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Stephen Pryor uh
subramanian and Jordan
short-livedi treats for medo and Jeff
Morrow for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
event until it finishes so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day